gM once designed a car that went 400
miles on a single strip of bacon that
car was never released because it's a
waste of bacon celery once challenged
bacon to a duel
that's why celery has no flavor the song
brown-eyed girl is about bacon it's just
a complicated metaphor numbnuts bacon
was invented by bacon I just blew your
mind that liquid that surrounds bacon in
the skillet
that's not grease that's just the
skillet crying tears of joy every word
you say has a silent bacon in it yes
fart blaster bacon doesn't clog your
arteries just reinforces something they
used to play rock paper scissors bacon
but they took out the bacon because
bacon always wins the average American
eats 100 pieces of bacon a year that
includes vegetarians and babies that
means even the average vegetarian baby
eats 100 pieces of bacon here at science
[ __ ] the only reason to put bacon in
the salad is to remind all the
vegetables that they suck the
higgs-boson gets its flavor by passing
through a field of bacon you freak nerd
in crisis situations bacon has been
known to fry itself just because it can
dickweed
the number-one cause of divorce is
something about bacon bacon bacon bacon
bacon bacon bacon bacon
your bong nugget
little turd temple just sack Dingle
you dirty nipple bag